so you guys have probably heard about
Arslan - Evo Evo proper a few months
later Oh blows oh that was a crazy
Arslan cementing his position as the
best second player on the planet he
basically put pakistani Tekken on the
map
Global tech it has never been so blessed
but here's the thing there's a guy who
might even be better than him 80 85
percent and for most ridiculous damage
working out right this is why people are
cheering no for Hawaii Sonny his name is
a why Sonny and you best bet he's coming
for the throne he plays a flashy and
aggressive style with Akuma a character
that's always been a bit of a wild card
in the world of Tekken
[Music]
Kumu mission now a Kula plays a lot like
he doesn't Street Fighter which is a
really different game
he's got stylish high damage combos and
he fundamentally breaks the rules of
Tekken he can do things and has access
to resources that few other characters
can do are so notch kicked in the door
for pakistani Tekken but honey is the
next player to make waves outside of a
country that it's notoriously hard to
travel to and from and at the FB Cup in
August
honey arrived in full force after being
knocked down to the loser's bracket by
well-known Japanese pro chica Rin he
went on an absolute tear before
obliterating me the god of Tekken
himself in the grand finals get this
[ __ ] apparently honey doesn't even own
his own stick and allegedly beat me
using borrowed hardware I didn't hear
that he thief maybe I think broke his
dick and he needed to borrow a stick for
that tournament which is crazy man for
different stick I mean just his
different tensions different feels and
you know it's just crazy to me that he
was able to win the tournament with a
high execution character using someone
else's ticket now for years Korea has
been home to some of Tekken's greatest
competitors while Pakistan has been a
secret hotbed of talent that nobody is
known about until recently arsalan said
that Pakistan has just as many Tekken
players as Japan you know that was
that's a huge statement it's been you
know just the amount of people that play
the game that the passion they have and
just prior to his performance at FV cup
honey signed with genuine gaming and
australian-based org
now that we have sponsors coming in the
most important thing that they can
provide is that support system to be
able to say hey guys we will deal with
all the administrative stuff we'll deal
with all that you know
boring stuff all you got to do is just
play the game that you love now the
craziest part about Hani's rise is that
he recently faced off against Arslan ash
at the all pakistan Tekken 7 dojo cop
and he [ __ ] won
[Applause]
and the coolest part about the Pakistan
dojo it was one of the first times the
global tacking community was paying
attention to a Pakistani tournament with
tournaments like this the curtain is
slowly being pulled back and Pakistani
Tekken footage is making its way to more
people and eventually we should see more
talent emerge from this region I know
there's a lot once it's out that I want
to but you need to take the steps inside
genuine gave me their day took the step
they said hey we're gonna listen to the
community we realize that there's more
good players on outside of our salon
they took her they took a risk I suppose
in sponsoring OS and they got their
return straightaway and I don't see why
other sponsors wouldn't do the same
thing now to be fair our Celyn said that
after his ebo win he did take a break
from Tekken but any way you slice it
honey is hot and he's itching to make a
name for himself what's so cool about
honey is what he represents of course
he's an absurdly talented Tekken player
but alongside Arslan - honey has the
opportunity to carve out a distinct path
to success in the fgc there's no
tried-and-true method for Pakistani
Tekken no rules to follow a concrete way
of doing things and that's exciting
because that means with competitors like
honey anything can happen
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages